l'académie française compte un nouvel
immortel l'écrivain françois cheng qui
est aussi calligraphe à ses heures
françois cheng a quitté la chine ya
l'âge de 20 ans vers paris sans parler
un mot de français à l'époque il est
ensuite tombé amoureux de notre pays et
de sa langue et ses premières oeuvres en
français date de 1970 pour françois
cheng la langue française et celle qui
traduit le mieux les sentiments
geneviève moll formule en soit il était
petit
fragile et timide dans la tête et dans
les étoiles
je suis émerveillé dit de lui même le
distinguera fait que depuis le fin fond
de la chine il ya soixante dix ans
arrivé en france dans le dénuement total
et après il a fallu une passion de ma
part pour apporter cette langue que
cette culture et à park est là favoriser
une sorte de dialogue entre les deux
cultures
d'abord à travers ses écrits sur la
peinture chinoise qu'il a entrepris ce
dialogue comme gustav mahler qui dans le
chant de la terre à magnifier la chine
ancienne vie locale des graphes nous a
restitué le lien entre la peinture
l'écriture et la philosophie
calligraphie important parce que la
calligraphie tabor près concilie celui
qui le fait avec univers des vivants
puisque c'est fondé sur l'idée du
souffle dont j'ai parlé ce vrai aussi
poétique et romanesque et des dames du
femina ne s'y sont pas trompés en
couronnant en 98 ledit de tanis
aujourd'hui première asiatique à entrer
à l'académie française il illustre
parfaitement l'universalité de la
culture pour moi la france c'est créer
une vocation c'est à dieu c'est de
tendre vers l'universel ce qui est son
cas qu un peu unique et grandiose donc
pour moi en tant que citoyen français
maintenant et en tant que academy 6 1
franc encore en tant que l'académicien
je compte bien un vrai dans ce sens là
en satin guette un homme rare que
d'emblée on a envie d'appeler m